we have a voicemail number that you can
call if you'd like to make your presence
known that number is
2192 David P here's a caller with a very
interesting question about Trump's fate
as a sex offender on the basis of the
finding against him in the E Gene
Carroll sexual assault and defamation
trial yesterday
uh yes David this is Alan calling from
Texas and I was just wondering will
Donald Trump be
forced to register on the sex offender
website since he was convicted of what
was it sexual battery or assault with
the Eugene Carroll case
uh could you let us know thank you the
answer is no Trump will not have to
register as a sex offender so I checked
in with a couple lawyer friends today
and this was my instinct the sex
offender registry is for people found
criminally liable criminally liable and
um because Trump was found I'm sorry
criminally guilty because Trump was
found civilly liable as a civil judgment
a monetary judgment the standard of
proof is different and it does not
require registering as a sex offender
now it is true that sex offender
registration laws vary by state and
every lawyer I spoke to very lawyerly
said to me
generally speaking civil liability in
sexual assault does not confer State Sex
Offender Registry but it's possible
there's some state where the laws differ
because the laws on this stuff do differ
from state to state but I was not able
to find any state in which you were
required to register as a sex offender
if you're found civilly liable for
sexual assault
um it's it's usually pretty specific
it's you must register as a sex offender
if you are criminally convicted of
specific offenses usually rape is listed
sexual assault child molestation child
molestation you know child porn charges
are often in there Etc I know that
you're not supposed to call it child
porn but I think everybody knows what
I'm talking about the Civil judgment
question
theoretically could depend on state law
it appears as though States could
require that those found civilly liable
for similar actions be required to
register but the belief of every
attorney I spoke to today is that there
is no state that currently has that
requirement so Trump as far as I know
will not have to register as a sex
offender on the basis of this finding we
have such a great bonus show for you
today although many of the stories are
sort of sad stories and disturbing
stories
the gunman who killed eight at the Texas
shopping mall over the weekend we now
know
had Neo-Nazi ideation and Neo-Nazi
tattoos still this isn't stopping some
on the right from saying it was a setup
it was a false flag or whatever the case
may be
um of course there's no evidence of that
there's evidence that he was a Neo-Nazi
although police are still searching for
the specific motivation in going to that
mall on that day I think it's fair to
say he was a Neo-Nazi we don't yet
necessarily know the motivation although
we can speculate but let's try not to
speculate and go with what we know so
we're going to talk about that on the
bonus show today secondly
this seems to happen again and again and
again
one of these anti-grooming Crusaders
he's a republican of course from Texas
he has now resigned because of sexual
misconduct he was involved in with a
teenage staffer or aide I think they
call them
yet again
yet again and lastly the subway crime
debate has been revived in New York City
because of this horrible choking death
that took place I have so much
experience with the New York subway and
I've seen it change to some degree over
the years I will weigh in with my
experiences on the subway as well as a
white looking guy right I think it's
fair to say sure I'm a Hispanic
immigrant from Argentina but I present
like a white guy a boring white guy
um and I know that that may be a factor
in my experiences versus the experiences
of others on the New York subway so
we'll talk about all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show please
sign up for the bonus show folks it
really is great oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad yeah okay I mean we do make money on
the bonus show but it also it really is
great and we'll talk about all of these
stories today you can sign up at
joinpakman.com
I believe our normal membership rates
are so reasonable so reasonable but if
you'd like a discount it's not means
tested it's available to whoever wants
it use the coupon code indicted and
you'll save roughly 50 all right
everybody see you in a few on the bonus
show we're back here tomorrow